vamos a resolver ahora el problema 138
en el problema 138 nos dicen que en
cierto negocio el índice de producción p
es directamente proporcional al índice
de eficiencia y entonces éste es igual a
una constante multiplicada por el índice
de eficiencia
y luego dice que a la vez el índice de
eficiencia es directamente proporcional
al índice de inversión y entonces
es directamente proporcional existe otra
constante ve tal que es igual a b porque
es directamente proporcional va aquí
creo que vale la pena decir que sí que
es directamente proporcional a y es
directamente proporcional a y entonces p
es directamente proporcional ahí es
decir existe una constante c al pp es
igual hace por iu y para verlo
matemáticamente simplemente tenemos que
sustituir este valor de en esta
expresión p es igual
por b por entonces la constante c sería
a por b vale bueno entonces tenemos esta
estas tres igualdades va y la pregunta
que nos hacen es cuánto vale p entonces
cuál es el valor de p si y
es igual a 70
muy bien vamos a ver que nos dan en los
incisos de información en el inciso 1 lo
que nos dicen es que es igual a 0.5 se
quedó fea y es igual a 0.5
sí y es igual a 60 sí y es igual a 60 ok
lo que nos dan aquí nos permite trabajar
con la segunda igualdad tenemos
información de e ide y entonces
tendríamos que 0.5 lo voy a poner como
un medio un medio es igual a iu por b es
igual a 60 b vale dividiendo entre 60 de
ambos lados b sería igual a 1 entre 120
pero esto en realidad todavía no nos da
forma de encontrar el valor de p a
partir del valor de verdad porque
simplemente nos está diciendo que está
constante la de esta proporción es uno
entre 120 pero para p para relacionarte
con y necesitamos a b y aa o bueno
necesitamos a su producto entonces por
el momento esta información no es
suficiente vamos a ver qué dice el
inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos dicen que p
p es igual a 0.2 sí y es igual a 50
es igual a 50 a ver este inciso por sí
mismo nos permite trabajar con esta
igualdad o con esta verdad y eso está
súper bueno nos dice que 0.2
0.2 es igual es igual hace por y hace
por 50 es igual a 50 ce entonces esta
igualdad de aquí nos permite determinar
el valor de ce o bien el valor de a por
b simplemente dividimos entre 50 de
ambos lados a ver 0.2 es lo mismo déjame
ponerlo como 2 entre 10 para que sea un
poco más fácil de pensar o bien como un
quinto como un quinto entonces a partir
de esta igualdad tenemos que ser es
igual a 1 entre 250
eso está muy bueno porque ahora sabemos
que aquí se vale uno entre 250 de modo
que p es igual a y entre 250 y con esto
ahora sí podemos responder esta pregunta
el valor de p cuando y vale 70 es igual
es igual a 70 entre 250 que sería igual
a 7 sobre 25 entonces la información del
inciso 2 fue suficientemente buena para
responder esta pregunta vale entonces la
respuesta sería b
muy bien vamos ahora al problema 139 en
el problema 139 nos dicen que x es
distinto de menos en la condición está
un poco rara y x es distinto de menos y
lo que nos piden determinar es si x
menos entre x + james / x mas es mayor
que 1 mayor que 1 a ok esta condición de
que x es distinto de menos es
simplemente para que no dividamos entre
0 me parece que pues es lo único o lo
único para lo cual vamos a necesitarla
pero bueno como le haríamos para
determinar que x menos entre x más es
mayor que 1 pues pudiéramos pasar
multiplicando este x + jr pero hay que
tener mucho cuidado verdad
tendríamos que verificar que fuera
positivo o bien si es negativo
tendríamos que cambiar el signo entonces
a lo mejor eso es un poco la tos o
déjame hacerle así para simplificar un
poco esta expresión lo que voy a hacer
es cambiar el numerador a
más o menos dos sale el denominador lo
voy a dejar igual como x más aquí no
hice nada menos 2 que sigue siendo menos
pero esto nos permite abrir esta
expresión como 1 x / x + 1 - 2 y entre x
+ y entonces si queremos ver que esta
expresión es mayor que 1
mayor que 1 lo que tenemos que verificar
es que 2 y entre x más con un signo
menos sea mayor que 0 vaya podemos
restar uno de ambos lados sin cambiar la
desigualdad de modo que esta desigualdad
es equivalente a menos ocho dividido
entre x más mayor que cero y
multiplicando por menos esto a su vez es
equivalente a 2 / / x +
menor que se va bueno entonces esta
expresión o esta desigualdad se da así
sólo sí o sea es equivalente a que se dé
esta de acá vamos a ver qué información
tenemos en los incisos en el inciso 1
nos dicen que x es mayor que 0 y nada
más si nada más tenemos esta información
sabemos muy poquito verdad o sea a lo
mejor x es mayor que 0 y lo de abajo es
positivo pero si lo de arriba es
negativo pues esto queda negativo pero
si ya es positivo entonces arriba queda
positivo con positivo entonces esto de
aquí es muy poca información no dice
nada acerca de y entonces esto no nos va
a permitir responder la pregunta y en el
inciso 2 nos dicen que es menor que cero
y otra vez estoy aquí solito no nos va a
permitir responder la pregunta verdad
porque no sabemos qué le sucede a x y
tampoco podemos pasarlo multiplicando
como si nada por lo de los signos
entonces por el momento estas dos no nos
han permitido decir nada al respecto qué
pasará si las juntamos si sabemos los
dos al mismo tiempo bueno déjame pensar
un poco
me parece que de todas formas no tenemos
información suficiente a ver qué sucede
si x es igual a 20 si x es igual a 20 y
james y es igual a menos 25 en este caso
pues en el numerador tendríamos algo
negativo negativo y en el denominador
también negativo nos quedaría negativo
entre negativo lo cual es igual a
positivo vale entonces aquí nos queda
algo positivo y si tenemos x igual a 20h
igual a menos 15
entonces el numerador una vez más queda
negativo pero ahora el denominador es 20
menos 15 que es 5 que quedaría algo
positivo y entonces la división sería
negativa negativa entonces tenemos estos
dos ejemplos que satisfacen a ambos
ambas condiciones de información pero
que nos dan resultados diferentes con
respecto al signo de esta expresión
entonces el inciso 1 y el inciso 2
aunque los juntemos no son suficientes
para responder la pregunta vale entonces
la respuesta sería eh
la respuesta es muy bien vamos al 140
vamos a un color un poco más brillante
que ya me dio algo de frío un color más
cálido color naranja nos dicen en el
plano cartesiano será cierto que los
puntos rs y v son equidistantes al
origen entonces queremos ver si la
distancia
del 0 0
a fs s
es igual a la distancia del 0 0 al v
ok a esta de aquí es la pregunta y
estamos en el plano cartesiano déjame
dibujar un plano cartesiano para
recordar un poco esto de la distancia la
distancia simplemente es utilizar el
teorema de pitágoras nada más que por
alguna razón nos hacen aprendernos
nuevos nombres y entonces memorizar
muchas cosas demás pero simplemente es
teorema de pitágoras por ejemplo si
tenemos un punto por aquí déjame ponerlo
en color rosa que es el punto a coma b
entonces para calcular la distancia
simplemente tenemos que ver cuál es esta
longitud pero esta longitud es la
hipotenusa de un triángulo rectángulo de
un triángulo rectángulo donde este lado
mide a justo porque eso es la coordenada
en x y esta altura me debe porque eso es
la coordenada n
entonces para determinar la distancia de
aquí para acá tenemos que ver si este
lado es decir raíz de a cuadrado o
tenemos que ver cuánto mide raíz
cuadrada + b cuadrada
es decir la distancia se obtiene
elevando al cuadrado los lados sumando
los y sacando raíz vale bueno entonces
esta pregunta de aquí es exactamente lo
mismo que hacerse la pregunta de si raíz
de re cuadrada más s cuadrada que es
igual a la raíz de cuadrada más b
cuadrada y como lo de adentro son
números positivos esto es exactamente lo
mismo que preguntarse si ere cuadrada
más s cuadrada es igual a 1 cuadrada
+ b cuadrado vale entonces nuestra
pregunta es esta de acá en realidad es
una pregunta algebraica muy bien vamos a
ver que nos dan en los incisos de
información en el inciso 1 voy a bajar
más va a tener espacio en el inciso 1 lo
que nos dicen es que r s es igual a 1 r
s es igual a 1 aquí no se ve por donde
esto nos va a dar información verdad
porque puede saber r está de este lado
es esta de este lado entonces a lo mejor
nos da información de la izquierda pero
pues de la derecha quien sabe entonces
pues no no verdad no sabemos nada de vtv
entonces este inciso por sí mismo yo
creo que no nos va a decir nada vamos a
ver qué nos dice el inciso 2 en el
inciso 2 nos dicen que u es igual a 1 -
r y que b es igual a 1 - s esto suena
mucho mejor porque nos permite cambiar
nuestra igualdad de cuatro variables a
una a una igualdad de únicamente dos
entonces vamos a ver qué sucede si
hacemos esta sustitución
acá sea lo que tendríamos que verificar
es si es re cuadrada más s cuadrada es
igual a 1 - r al cuadrado más 1 - s al
cuadrado y esto que es a ver esto de
aquí es igual a 1 al cuadrado menos dos
veces r más r al cuadrado más vamos con
este de acá 1 al cuadrado menos dos
veces ese más s al cuadrado más éste al
cuadrado simplemente eso es un binomio
al cuadrado verdad una diferencia al
cuadrado entonces aquí que nos quedan
esto de aquí es igual
a ver o sea si queremos que se cumpla
esta igualdad necesitamos que r al
cuadrado más s al cuadrado sea igual a
dos menos dos veces r s más s más r
cuadrada más s cuadrada ok entonces para
que se cumpla esta igualdad pues lo que
podemos hacer es cancelar estos de ambos
lados y pedir que 0 sea igual a 2 - 2
por cc.oo bien sumando dos veces además
s de ambos lados pedir que dos veces se
rebasen sea igual a dos y todavía
podemos simplificar lo un poco más hay
que pedir que ese sea igual a uno va
entonces la información del inciso 2 nos
permite reducir nuestra igualdad a que
necesitamos que r s sea igual a 1 hasta
aquí nada más con el inciso 2 no podemos
decir que esto sea cierto pero esa justo
es la información que está en el inciso
entonces el inciso 2 así solito nos
sirve el inciso 1 tampoco sirve
juntando los dos si podemos determinar
que las distancias son iguales entonces
en este problema la respuesta sería c
vale se juntando las dos podemos
responder la pregunta le voy a dejar
hasta aquí nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo para continuar con estos problemas